the city of pompeii was a prosperous hub
of commerce well before it was settled
by romans in the year 80 bc
but little did these roman settlers know
that their time in the city was to be
cut short by a natural disaster of
monumental proportions
hi i'm rich burnett for one dream
in this episode of perspectives three
historians paint a picture of ancient
pompeii covering culture famous citizens
and ultimately the eruption of mount
vesuvius in the year 79 a.d
we begin now early in the roman
occupation as they imposed their own
values onto their prized new city
[Music]
pompeii becomes a roman colony under the
dictator salah founded in 80 bc
with the patron of the colony being the
dictator's nephew publius solo and so
he's paying particular attention to
pompei and putting his own nephew in
charge down here and i think that gives
you a sense of how important pompe was
to this entire region
with the foundation of the roman colony
in adbc we see the imposition of roman
urban and social forms on the city and
what we see down here are
roman constructions that are designed to
reflect roman cultural identity and one
of the places we're going to start to
see that is in the house of the fawn
where we will see the salutatio ceremony
this is the morning greeting ceremony
that takes place
the house of the fawn was a large house
here in pompeii it's actually two houses
built in the same night period
that were put together in 80 bc so that
we have now one house that takes up an
entire city block you can see i think if
you look at the facade of the house of
the phone it's sam knight origins we
have those large blocks of kind of
honey-colored stone that we saw in the
house of salist
tall 15 foot tall doorway flanked by
greek style pilasters
this gives you a sense of the samnite
character but it's all heavily renovated
for the romans now the name of the house
of the fawn comes from the inside and i
wanted to show you this wire statue
because what we have here is a copy of
the statue of the fawn from the interior
of the house of the fog
as you entered the house of the fawn the
the first main room is the atrium this
is standard in these roman style houses
and in the atrium there's this little
statuette of the fawn and it faces the
doorway we've got it placed so you can
see it as you would entering the house
in antiquity
and it's a marvelous opportunity because
you get this sense of what this is like
this fawn really represents the
integration of greek culture into roman
domestic space even at the very highest
levels because this was the house of the
patron of the colony
sulla the nephew of the dictator and
this is the image that greets you when
you walk in is an image of dionysiac
greek mythology are fawn so the fawn is
something of a touchstone here
the walls lining the streets of pompeii
were typically plastered and whitewashed
to discourage burglars most houses
lacked large ground level windows
resulting in long tempting stretches of
white surfaces
these expanses were exploited by a wide
spectrum of people who painted or
incised messages ranging from the
political to the personal
much graffiti was related to commercial
activity it appears to have been common
practice to advertise rooms for rent by
painting a sign on the wall
one example for upscale property states
for rent the arius polio apartment
building owned by nias alias [ __ ]
mayas
street front shops with counter space
luxury second-story apartments and a
townhouse available beginning july 1st
interested parties should contact primus
the slave of nias alias nigidis mayas
pompeii's electoral graffiti even supply
a glimpse of the
dirty tactics that some politicians
might employ
one strategy was to slander your
opponent by putting up graffiti
that appeared to offer endorsements of
him by undesirable groups
the enemies of a man named vatia seem to
have been particularly fond of this
tactic they painted a number of such
notices including
the petty thieves ask you to elect
vadiya's aedile
and the late sleepers ask you to elect
vadiya's adile
and also all the drunkards ask you to
elect marcus cyrinius vatia-edile papaya
was born in about 31 and grew up in the
pompeii region in southern italy
pompeii was a beautiful prosperous town
overlooking the sparkling bay of naples
with the smoking mount vesuvius in the
background
the volcano wouldn't bury the town until
48 years later when papaya grew up there
it was a perfect roman town with about
11 000 people
it was prosperous and dotted with
beautiful villas as visitors to the
ruins today can see
as soon as papaya became pregnant with
nero's child the emperor divorced
octavia when the people of rome
protested he had octavia banished to an
island and then murdered
nero had octavia's head delivered to
papaya
i suppose she saw it as an engagement
gift
the people of rome rioted at the death
of octavia she was popular and
considered a worthy family member of the
divine augustus in their riots they
destroyed the statues of papaya blaming
her for the death of octavia
reputedly papaya didn't care
she was consolidating her power over the
young ruler
how has posterity remembered papaya
the ancient historian josephus portrayed
her as a pious religious seeker
while tacitus and others remember her as
ambitious
ruthless and murderous
modern portrayals in art and movies from
quavadas to i claudius and many others
emphasize her beauty sexuality and
ruthlessness
as well as her abuse by the notorious
emperor
at the end of the day papaya expresses
the life of many men and women at the
heights of power of the roman empire
the best of them were lured in device
and murder by the huge power of the
imperial title
the worst of them indulged their vices
but still
sometimes expressed their humanity
few however had the long-standing
influence of papaya whose combination of
spirituality and cruelty
launched the murderous age of martyrs
that extended from 64 to 313 when
emperor constantine put a stop to the
periodic persecutions
[Music]
we know of her from several inscriptions
one of these was found on a large and
imposing structure that was built right
next to the central forum surrounded by
the city's temples and law courts
the inscription reads yumakia a public
priestess of the goddess venus
the daughter of lucius had these
courtyards colonnades and porticos
constructed using her own money and they
are dedicated in her own name and that
of her son
in honor of the goddesses concord and
augustine piety
this is a remarkable inscription in that
it identifies one of the most prominent
public buildings in the entire city
as having been paid for and built by a
woman
a woman who furthermore was able to
proudly state this fact in large letters
carved right across its facade for all
to see
inside the building was found a statue
of yumakia herself with an accompanying
inscription indicating that it had been
erected in her honor by the guild of
fuller's
this suggests that yumaki was a
successful and wealthy businesswoman who
had amassed a fortune in the laundry
trade probably by owning several
fooleries
collectively the inscriptions the statue
and the building itself give testimony
that in first century a.d pompeii
yumakia was a respected prosperous and
well-known member of the community
so much so that she had been honored by
being appointed a priestess of venus and
could serve as a patron to the entire
guild of fuller's
now here we are it's the morning of
august 24th 79 a.d and mount vesuvius is
where it's been for the last 23 000
years dominating the planes around the
bay of naples it's about 6 000 feet tall
roughly cone shaped and
sometime
prior to midday on 79 a.d we don't know
how long it occurred but there was an
enormous buildup of volcanic gas down at
the base inside the mountain
sometime about midday
that enormous buildup of volcanic gas
ignited and because of that ignition the
eruption begins with a massive explosion
almost immediately the top half of the
mountain is pulverized so picture first
off about the top three thousand feet of
the mountain gone it's pulverized into
what's termed an eruptive column this
column of hot ash and pumice is thrown
into the air easily over two miles high
and some estimates suggest over five
miles into the air and that eruptive
column of material is going to hang
there until it loses the battle against
gravity and the prevailing winds
meanwhile and remember i said this is a
complex eruptive event meanwhile there
are what are called pyroclastic flows
and these are flows of other material
coming directly out of that crater the
remains of the
volcano vesuvius coming out of the
crater what we have are these enormous
flows of
hot material and this material is a
mixture of superheated steam
ash mud and rock that flows out of the
crater it's dense
and so it hugs the flanks of the
mountain and flows down through gravity
down to the lowest areas around vesuvius
it's hot it's probably up to about a
thousand degrees fahrenheit and it's
giving off so much heat immediately that
it glows and it flows down the flanks of
the mountain at about 450 miles an hour
it's so
dense hot and fast that when it flows
over small bodies of water like small
ponds and lakes it actually just
instantly vaporizes the water on the
surface that turns into more superheated
steam and accelerates the speed
most of those pyroclastic flows come
down and hit the west side of the
mountain so on the south side is largely
ash and pumice and that of course is
where pompeii and stabia are the west
side between the base of of the mountain
and the sea is of course right where
herculaneum is and that's where those
pyroclastic flows come down and really
devastate that area
okay that's the sequence
[Music]
hey thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about the topics in this
episode the full list of series that
these clips came from is in the
description below you can watch them all
on one dream and don't forget to
subscribe to this youtube channel for
new episodes of perspectives and you can
watch previous ones here
[Music]